the world's most senior diplomat is in
moscow on a mission
un secretary general antonio guterres
says he has come to the russian capital
as a messenger of peace
his audience the most controversial
world leader at the moment
russian president vladimir putin who
received the secretary general with high
praise for his organization
russia as one of the founding countries
of the united nations and a permanent
member of the security council has
always supported this universal
organization and we believe that it is
not just universal but unique in its
kind there is no such organization in
the international community and we
strongly support the principles on which
it is based and we intend to do so in
the future
guterres seemingly not mincing any words
about how the united nations sees
russia's so-called special military
operation in ukraine
i understand these grievances but from
our perspective the grievances must be
solved according to the different
instruments that the un charter has at
its disposal and the one thing that we
firmly believe is that the violation of
the territorial integrity of a country
is completely out of order in relation
to the charter
earlier in the day guterres kicked off
his trip with a meeting at the russian
foreign ministry and a working lunch
with sergey lavrov
the two officials discussed for nearly
two hours the situation in ukraine
they emerged from what was described as
a frank conversation
it is clear that there are two different
positions on what is happening in
ukraine
according to the russian federation what
is taking place is a special military
operation
with the objectives that were announced
according to the u.n in line with
resolutions passed by the general
assembly russia's invasion of ukraine is
a violation of its territorial integrity
and against the charter of united
nations
the russian foreign minister once again
defended his country's decision
this was happening as a result of the
actions of the us and its allies and the
unipolar world as for our geopolitical
sphere it was done in the interest of
containing russia and to that end for
many years ukraine has been used as a
springboard to restrain our country
one of the main initiatives put forward
by the secretary general involved ending
the humanitarian crisis in the besieged
port city of mariopol
the city is now under russian control
according to the defense ministry
but thousands of civilians are unable to
leave it something vladimir putin
dismissed as misinformation
gutierrez has proposed setting up a
contact working group made up of russian
ukrainian and u.n members to ensure that
all residents wishing to leave can do so
and to allow aid into the area
after a two-hour meeting with the
russian president the u.n says vladimir
putin has agreed in principle to the
involvement of the agency along with the
international committee of the red cross
to oversee the evacuation of civilians
from the azov stall steel plant in
mariopol
the un secretary general seemingly
managed to achieve what many world
leaders have failed to do so far
as he travels to ukraine he will be
looking for officials there to approve
this plan as well
all the while the nearly one thousand
civilians continue to wait to get out of
the underground tunnels in one of
europe's largest steel plants
dorsojabari al jazeera moscow